the Shinobi crouched low on the Pagoda
roof and listened to the night air up
here in the mountains away from the
hustle and bustle of the markets in town
it was almost silent just the distant
rattle of shutters somewhere behind him
the mountain Shrine was tucked out of
sight so far into the countryside that
no one would stumble onto it by accident
no one would come here without a reason
the Shinobi knew the face of his Target
a warlord turned politician with more
blood on his hands than the Assassin
sent to kill him by the burning glow of
the night sky the Shinobi could see the
man kneeling at The Shrine the path was
made up of small stones so he'd have to
drop onto the grass and creep around the
pond to approach his Target no guards no
one else was there at all this was the
spot where the man came to pray when he
was struggling to sleep perhaps trying
to atone for the lives he'd taken
perhaps he didn't care at
the ninja drew the blade in total
silence and time just dropped to the
ground with the rattling noise in the
distance with each dainty step he closed
the distance to his Target readying the
blade over his head it was done in a
moment the man was dead before his body
hit the ground he likely didn't even
notice as the steel had severed the
nerves running down his spinal cord so
Shard was the blade that had slid
through his bones like a fish through
water raising the blade to his eyes the
Shinobi cleaned it quickly if he was
seen with blood on his sword he would
immediately be implicated not that he
was ever seen But precautions like this
were what kept him out of sight for all
these years when you lived in The Valley
Of Ashes the burial grounds for
countless Wars you had to become a
shadow become one of the ancient Spirits
haunting the woods but as he wiped the
red from the steel he caught a flash of
light in the reflection an orange glow
marking a jagged line across the metal
that's strange Sunset was several hours
ago come to think of it why was there an
orange glow in the sky he snapped his
neck around to see the fires through the
gates into the pagoda's garden down by
the Ocean's Edge at the foot of the
mountains was the city where he had
always lived and it was on fire leaping
up onto the walls he stood up straight
surveying the horror scene taking place
before him thick plumes of smoke
billowed up into the night sky so dense
and large that it seemed to become the
Blackness of the night it was hard to
make out much of what was going on down
there the Shinobi looked everywhere to
try to see the invading army or the
rioters but there were none just people
running in all directions like ants out
of a flooding Nest but there moving in
amongst the smoke were other shapes
impossibly tall lumbering around like
people people that towered over the
houses that had to Crane down to the
ground to scoop up the poor civilians
who were running this way and that the
Shinobi stood there terrified as he
realized the rattling sound he'd been
hearing all night wasn't from any
shutters at all he could do nothing but
watch as the trees in front of him
trembled and buckled in all directions
as a hulking shadowy figure lumbered
towards him the Imperial Japanese
anomalous matters examination agency or
the ija mea was a Japanese agency
responsible for tracking a number of
mysterious and often dangerous artifacts
creatures and anomalies prior to the
second world war in 1945 the ijamaa was
shut down and absorbed into the SCP
Foundation all of these data historic
records and anomalies were all
transferred over into the foundation's
control reasons for this were partially
political and partially in the interest
of world peace the formation of the
ijmea was influenced heavily by Japan's
ties with Germany in the first half of
the 2 20th century the Imperial German
anomalous matters examination agency was
the blueprint for their Japanese
equivalent however with increasing
militarism in Japan throughout the 20th
century the ijmea became increasingly
obsessed with trying to harness their
anomalous discoveries in the interests
of military power their goal became the
establishment of a Yokai Battalion
powerful enough to establish them as one
of if not the world's greatest
superpower following the bombings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki Japan surrendered
in the second world war and agreed to
dissolve its military including the ija
mea that left the foundation with the
task of picking up the threads left
behind and trying to come up with new
ways of securing containing and
protecting some of Japan's most
deadliest scps few more deadly and
evasive than the entities that were too
much even for the Yokai Battalion
scp-2863 in 1946 cleanup operations were
in full effect trying to deal with the
Fallout from the atomic bomb dropped on
Nagasaki Crews dressed in bloodline
suits worked Around the Clock burying
radioactive material and trying to
remove as much contaminated debris as
possible rebuilding this city was still
a long way off at various points the
wind would kick up and carry the dust
Left Behind into the air creating a
dangerous radioactive Haze Crews
continued to work through such
conditions as the understanding of
Airborne contamination was still in its
infancy Watanabe Goro was one such
worker Midway through a night shift and
clasping a damp rag to his mouth he
pushed on through the dust clearing out
building after building they had spent
the morning carrying corpses out of an
unidentifiable building the corpses
themselves were pretty much worn away
too just skeletons really charred by the
blast from months before asgoro
staggered along the street he kept
feeling like he was imagining things the
long hours and traumatic conditions were
enough to make him see all kinds of
things in his dreams but he kept feeling
like his dreams were starting to creep
into the real world Shadows kept moving
through the haze all around him taller
than buildings staggering around as if
they were drunk they had been appearing
all night just out of sight but always
close by he stopped and leaned against
what was left of a brick wall there was
one of his hallucinations now just up
ahead of him the husks of buildings on
either side of him were about as tall as
their knees it must have been 30 meters
tall at least but its legs were strange
there seemed to be a gap in the middle
of each of them they were skinny no
skeletal the skeleton's foot crushed a
car right in front of him the crunch of
metal was loud enough to snap Goro out
of his stupor this wasn't a
hallucination hallucinations can't crush
cars with the lp tumbled backwards
staring up into the haze of dust he saw
the shape of a pelvis above it what must
have been a rib cage the size of his
house but the creature disappeared into
the darkness and the dust if it was too
tall for him to see its face maybe it
was too tall to see him on the ground as
well the skeleton stopped standing
directly over him for a second he
thought that maybe he'd be okay but then
with a great rattling Rumble the monster
hunched down low and the enormous skull
appeared out of the haze flying right
towards him he managed to dodge its
gnashing teeth but it caught his foot
sending him rolling through the
radioactive dirt Goro didn't give
himself a moment to recover though he
took off running as fast as he could
hearing the rattling sound terrifyingly
close behind his back you will be
pleased to know that Watanabe Goro
survived this incident with only minor
injuries he managed to navigate his way
to the nearest police station where SCP
agents already familiar with the entity
he had encountered took control of this
situation the so-called starving
skeletons had been filming the bomb
sites for several weeks by that point it
was the foundation's first exposure to
one of the oldest known entities that
the ija mea had been studying for years
to date 206 separate instances of
scp-2863 have been officially recorded
however the myth of the gasha dokoro had
been circulating in various parts of
Japan since the 10th Century at least
giant skeletons were said to haunt the
sights of particularly deadly battles
hunting by night and feeding on the
blood of their human victims these myths
tally up with what the foundation
currently knows about these entities
instances of
scp-2863 only appear after Sunset and
will lose all Corporal reality when
exposed to sunlight in the morning or
any light source over 1.1 Lux to give
you some reference for that Moonlight
typically Falls between 0.25 and 1 Lux a
typical room with the light on will be
100 or even 1 000 times brighter as you
can imagine this has made them virtually
impossible to contain as they manifest
and unmanifest outside of controllable
conditions they seem to have continuous
existence in some way however as
previously neutralized instances can and
will reappear later on in folklore the
gashodokoro are spirits that take
control of skeletons some hesitant
researchers have posited that perhaps
the instances that dematerialize are
returning to their Spirit form little is
understood about what that means in
practice what's more this SCP cannot be
photographed all attempts to capture
them on film or digital cameras have
failed including video tests it is
theorized that there is a link between
them not appearing on camera and their
disappearance when exposed to light
again the link between them is still
mostly unknown due to a steady increase
in urban development in Japan and
ongoing peace in the region appearances
of this SCP are growing increasingly
rare her while this marks a positive
change for the people of Japan it makes
it even more difficult to study this SCP
and learn how to prevent it in the
future the most recent fatality to occur
at the Bony hands of
scp-2863 happened in 2008 and it was
part of a foundation experiment While
most of Hiroshima and Nagasaki had been
redeveloped into bustling metropolitan
areas the outskirts of each City
particularly several Parks saw
occasional instances of
scp-2863 appearing at night as such the
SCP Foundation conducted a series of
experiments under cover of Nightfall
releasing d-class Personnel into a park
in Hiroshima to observe how the scps
hunted humans their enormous height
towering at over 30 meters gave them a
huge Advantage being able to chase
people down with little difficulty
another notable thing about them is just
how quietly they move there is a gentle
rattling sound that follows them around
but aside from that they are very light
footed and difficult to detect until
they are right on top of you this isn't
helped by the fact that they hunt at
night as a result they are remarkably
quick at catching their prey once they
have snatched their victims up in their
skeletal fingers they perform the same
eating ritual every time they eat the
person and consume their blood initially
confused by this finding the foundation
was unsure where the blood was going as
the skeletons had no obvious digestive
system after the release of several more
d-class Personnel into the park they
still weren't certain but they believed
that the SCP instances were absorbing
the blood into their bones in some way
further testing was requested but denied
due to the sheer number of d-class
fatalities in the area they were
starting to run out and would have to
ship more of them across to Japan which
was just a bit inconvenient for everyone
involved as the outskirts of those
cities have been urbanized the instances
of scp-2863 have reduced to the point
that a smaller attention of agents and
researchers are now left in place the
light pollution from these areas is
enough to prevent them from being able
to manifest in the first place for the
most part only on the rare occasion of
power outages have mobile task force
zero three been deployed whilst
researching this SCP the foundation came
across an account from a Shinobi in the
1700s it was rare to find any kind of
written document from a ninja for
obvious reasons but the account
discovered painted a harrowing picture
of just how much damage these Yokai
could inflict upon a city the nameless
Shinobi first encountered
scp-2863 while assassinating an unnamed
Target in the mountains above his
fishing Town looking down on the fires
below him he saw human shapes walking
through the smoke dwarfing the buildings
they move between before an instance
charge through the trees straight at him
diving out of the way the Shinobi
quickly melted into the Shadows both man
and Demon hunted one another throughout
the night he managed to climb onto its
spine and conflict what he was certain
would be a killing blow to the skeleton
only for his blade to bounce right off
the bone caught and vulnerable for the
first time in his life the Shinobi was
helpless as the spirit threw him from
its back into the courtyard and charged
at him it was only the Hem of the Ninja
sleeve Catching Fire from a candle that
saved him just as the skeleton was about
to bite down on his head the light
flared and the SCP disappeared entirely
for a long while the man lay in the
courtyard pondering his actions ye
should have died that night yet he
survived getting slowly to his feet the
man now knew what his Destiny was a
monster that strikes from the Shadows
scared of the light he and the
gashodokuru were not so different
understanding his Target was the first
step to defeating them snatching up a
lantern from the ground the Shinobi
descended the mountain into the wreckage
of his hometown and defended his people
by night he would emerge hunting down
the gashodokuru under the cover of
Darkness banishing down with the light
hidden under a dark sheet the man fought
night after night narrowly risking death
to save his people from the onslaught of
the evil spirit a small plaque was
installed by the ijamea shortly before
the foundation took over the management
of the SCP it was installed at the foot
of an old Pagoda just outside a small
fishing Village on it was a simple Haiku
walking in Shadow in the midst of our
demons we will find the light now check
out
scp-2662 Cthulhu and scp-2935 o death
for more